[Music]
welcome we promised some hello Kermit we
promised someday that we're gonna invest
in a better camera for this the day is
coming it will happen well we're
thinking about consolidating because we
have a couple cameras if my camera that
I used to shoot my videos and then this
camera and then you have Bloggie your
camera but we're thinking about maybe
taking this camera and my video camera
and trading them in for an upgrade yeah
one camera that does that does both the
DSLR but you can get a camera that's
good as quality as a DSLR but also
shoots long term like podcast right my
camera doesn't shoot photography so the
days and it takes beautiful video but
the day I mean it's just it doesn't
video for longer than 10 minutes or hour
the day is coming where we look like a
legitimate podcast but the day is not
coming when we sound like a Sun yes we
are rapture we have the ranch at am
ratchet you know what I just thought of
oh it's probably gonna work though what
one well because we've been in our
makeshift office the aka the dining room
for a while now physically the leak in
the actual office when we moved in here
I was so pumped that we were gonna have
like a space till I closed the door and
have all this equipment everywhere and
like then you shut it out of your leg
cuz it like starts to make you go crazy
nope nope just kidding
um but I was thinking maybe we could
like make a formal podcast setting in
the [ __ ] craft utility room or
something yeah set up all
yeah make it exciting it's possible it's
possible it's definitely something I
mean I'd love to have a setting where we
have like our chairs already there maybe
something cool in the background paper
curtains to look at yeah like we could
definitely set something cool up but
along with that comes some planning and
obviously new camera so maybe in the
future but you know what it's worth it
it's a project worth pursuing because
it's we care about the podcast so we
want to look good this dining room setup
is killing me after a little while yeah
we need a we need to get past this I
miss my dining room table I know we
haven't even played beer pong on this
thing yet how are we no that's a shame I
know all right so as soon as we're done
shooting tonight we're moving everything
back noms came we'll do it soon though
or something is this very echoey yeah we
got a rug and get we can get some stuff
for the walls yeah like when I was
recording my Sirius XM show in there it
was like super Donuts yeah you could
hear on the radio too this kind of yeah
but then you yeah I mean you start to
put a blanket over your head or whatever
we're not gonna be ghetto and ratty like
that will get foam for the walls and get
a rug so it's not just like bouncing off
everything the sound pulling the sound
good all right Julian what are we doing
today
well her Jenna's idea which I am very
happy with we are gonna play the
newlyweds game is that we're not
newlyweds
we've been newlywed we're married and so
we're gonna play the newlyweds game no I
thought it would be funny like to play a
game to see like how well we know each
other or these are particularly deep
questions well they're questions that
were I feel like we could get them all
the same but there's gonna be a couple
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] funny ones like I feel
like you were just sitting over there
trolling we wrote our answers oh it's
not trolling I was just honestly
thinking like when we were talking about
like what I wanted to be when I grew up
I didn't know I had a thing about that
jeez so yeah we prepared 30 questions
that we both answered about each other
and our relationship I guess sort of
yeah and we we have them on cards for
you so we are gonna do that peach why do
you always get wild the moment we start
the podcast peachy stop getting wild
she's like going is gone wild over there
you take your top off relax she's like
all right shall we start the newlyweds
I'm ready I'm excited all right let's
start first first question yeah my
favorite color what's Julian's favorite
color okay do I do I say it or do we
just hold up the card hold up your card
Oh whoever it's not about reads their
answer first okay ready go
no what's Julian's favorite color I said
Julian's favorite color is Julian yellow
what is it Julian electric yellow epic
for those of you who don't know that's
that like hot neon yellow yeah it's like
what Nike makes their shoes I'm just a
bit I'm just a fan of electric yellow
because we call it Julian yo nice work
thanks all right Dean point Jenna's
favorite color
I guess purple I said Julian yellow
[Laughter]
because as soon as Mikey Mikey really
started pumping out the that like right
yellow Julian was so obsessed with it
he's like oh dude oh it's just the best
color oh my god so then every time we
saw that color
I even got you like from each and every
first started doing like these earrings
and a bracelet to match that we're
Julian yellow I was like damn I can't
leave I found these I don't care if you
like them I'm getting them
they're my color you can enjoy them or
not
I am already enjoying them I still paint
my nails that color all the time my
toenails our car so don't see when
you're tan that [ __ ] look sick pale girl
problems
it's January you can't just walk around
with the illness you go down oh we still
gotta go tanning
I miss tanning I feel so good you're
just like I cannot tan anymore because I
worked at the tanning salon for years
I'd be used my tanning it's not good I
have yet to have used my ten it's not
good for you I feel so good though you
just feel like after a workout you're
like I need the vitamin D and then you
get it you know if you want to get into
things that feel great but are horrible
for you you should just get into [ __ ]
heroin
well okay then on to our next question
tanning is not as bad as a heroin but
it's pretty [ __ ] bad for you
especially if you're like me and my
skin's really pale and I just abuse that
spray tan is dick doll huh fair enough
next question who's the better cook what
did you hold it up
no but read it for the people that are
listening Julian the tornado I wrote me
and she wrote Julian the tornado why
don't you explain that answer can I
change my twitter name to Julian the
tornado right now is it taken I think
the best way to describe it was like
when we first started hanging out and
you would cook stuff I was like
flabbergasted how quickly you could just
make something until I realized it's
because he takes every ingredient are
the refrigerator or the cabinets just
leaves it wherever cuts things takes a
knife sets it down like you're cutting
butter and just like leaving butter like
you just literally leaves there's a path
of destruction and then before you know
it like he's up but bingo-bango
and then you look at the kitchen and
she's like like you're cooking eggs but
there's just like eggshells everywhere
like you don't clean up at all while
you're cooking which is why you're able
to cook at a pace that doesn't make any
sense like I think the best example was
for Mother's Day and we my mom was in
town her mom was in town
yeah she's came over and you were
cooking like three pounds of bacon and
like a hundred eggs and my mom you know
you you cooked all that in like ten
minutes and it was so much it was like
two and a half packs of bacon and like
maybe a carton of eggs just cuz everyone
was coming over so yeah my sister yeah
my mom just looked at you at ten minutes
he cooked all of this and my mom's just
like go look at the kitchen right now so
that's why we're Julian's definitely a
better cook because he definitely cooks
a lot of things really fast really well
so like if you're ever starving Julian
is the person to feed you because he
will have it in your mouth in t-minus
like 40 seconds but then the kitchens
but yeah r.i.p but that's why like you
cook really well and then i'm just
walking around just cleaning up your
destruction and like helping you get the
ingredients and stuff tornado all right
absolutely
I'm glad you described it like that also
I'd like to note that I feel like when
you leave the fridge open while you're
cooking it makes you cook master it's
just like a proven it's so mad I would
like come home from wherever I was Oh
Kermit God the farts oh do you smell no
get him a tea God I would like come home
from whatever is doing and their
refrigerator it would be like wide open
I like Julian I like Texan did you leave
the [ __ ] refrigerator open like what
were you doing did you
to rope but I left there Fred yeah but a
couple of times because like if I'm
getting things in and out of it while
I'm cooking I'm like I leave it open cuz
I gotta do this fast and then sometimes
like I'll just I'll just finish and I'll
just like black out wake up in the other
room after eating the food and the
fridge is still it's just so foreign to
me because I've never met anyone like
that like I just don't know how that
works like he'll leave all the cabinets
open like everybody open yeah I bumped
my head on cabinets so many times just
open okay the worst though is when
you're cooking this is my like pet peeve
about you cooking because I was a
babysitter for so many years and they're
so dangerous when you have a pan and you
leave the handle like out so that if you
were walking by you would just knock the
whole pan off the stove and then burn it
so every time I'm cooking she like takes
the pan and slides the handle away from
the edge of the corner in towards the
stove and then I turn around and he's
got it all the way out he's like don't
look babe I'm paying attention how many
casualties have we had none none yeah
but none because every three seconds I
turn it back into this I just keep
waiting for you one day to like slip or
knock it or just walk into it and then
you burn one of the dogs or oh you know
it'll be well deserved they would have
just Dutch happened us okay too far all
right no it's not gonna happen not going
you just knock down what so won't happen
I'm gonna be better at it I'm gonna be
less of a tornado you're such a tornado
yeah but you cook me food food so I
can't really complain them as you like
that tornado yeah that's why it's a
funny joke but it's really it's all
business because I accept my tornado
wake destruction duty yes absolutely
because you feed the [ __ ] out of me oh
who takes longer to get dressed
Jenna duh question what what come on
like bogey you're like you you take
exponentially longer than I do you take
Julian's squared
what did I want to be when I when I was
growing when I want what I want to be
when I grew up when I was a kid what did
when Julian was 13 what did he want to
be when he grew up what I said Julian
wanted to be a catcher a baseball player
I wrote artist slash baseball player so
you're right yeah dude we're all right
we're crushing it
what did Jenna want to be when she grew
up when she was 13 what's your answer
makeup artist oh I forgot about that
you're right though mine's wrong what
did I write no [ __ ] clue well Jenna
always told me that like when she was a
kid she loved the idea of makeup and
doing makeup on people and just like
having it be an art and [ __ ] being
great at it and she she like loved it
and she went to her dad one time and she
was like dad I want to do this like I
want to be good at I want to be a
professional I want to do this when I
grow up I want to be a makeup artist and
her dad was like that's not a job and
then you got discouraged and then
stopped playing yeah well I mean I'm
sure if you were to ask him today he
would deny ever saying that that's the
story she always told me well it's true
though that's exactly what he said my
dad's a chemist and Devin's like a you
know material science engineer and I
think the gist of what he was trying to
tell me it was that I needed to stay in
school go to college
but you can go to [ __ ] school high
school yeah for my sister's friend did
that right and it's obviously a huge
career now dad like even uh easily have
a job doing makeup or whatever the [ __ ]
you want but I was so Harper Lee that's
really cute though [ __ ] clue and you
wrote what I did actually wanted to be
when I was like 13 I was just so like
sad I'm like what do you mean sour real
childhood this book I have Bobby Brown's
book I have Kevin ah Cohen's book like
I've always people makeup artists books
reading through them how successful they
are and happy the way you did become
your own makeup artist cuz you have kind
of coined your own look which is about
one of the most popular sorry people
like your makeup don't sell yourself
short there oh it's pretty whoo G ha ha
ha it's cool but your ha I mean I'm
crushing it right now for those who they
can't see
the natural Jena is on juego
you're not in Marx here all right get
away
who is Julian's Hall Pass all right so
who's the person that I get to have sex
with if we have us I do it first it's
about you don't show you yet okay ready
yeah
who's my Hall Pass because I think I
know who this is but I think that it
would surprise people Amy Poehler
Pollard yeah I only pick her as my Hall
Pass because she's an incredible
hilarious woman I'm sorry there's no
reasoning other than that it's just
she's a god Leslie [ __ ] know when we
first started hanging out and it was
like talking about that topic or
whatever and you're like Amy Poehler and
I'm like what the [ __ ] like is that
serious like are you just trying to like
throw me for a loop over here like Amy
Poehler and he's like I'm dead serious
dead [ __ ] serious really like sir
she's dope she's dope she makes me laugh
harder than anyone except for Jenna ever
yeah but you're usually laughing at me
that's right like half a ton
all right who's your all Beth you ready
yeah I feel like there's a couple
answers that would accept here okay you
Seth MacFarlane I would accept that
answer
I wrote GSP okay [ __ ] you okay but I
have to all right so here's my read I
feel like
Seth MacFarlane is gay I'm not having it
as gay I don't care I don't care I don't
care you get some of his Hall Pass just
go like to lunch or something
no GSP I mean he's so legendary like you
wouldn't be able to talk to him let
alone Hall Pass I know when we're at the
fight what fight was that
whatever doesn't matter we're in Vegas
and he walked like right in front of me
and Julian was like I'll just say hi
because the girl in front of us was
asking for a picture
Ashida Weidman yeah and he was being you
know totally polite oh yeah and he was
like in the flesh like 10 feet away from
us yeah and I Julian was like oh just
like say hi say hi he's right I was like
frozen she didn't work out like it just
hit her like could it couldn't chicken
she couldn't even so but I feel like
that's happening you know they say never
meet your heroes and that's everything
but like I wouldn't say that GSP is my
hero I just said the caliber of your
hero that's true yeah but [ __ ]
remember we got invited to the Sam Smith
concert to meet Sam Smith yeah I was
like I can't meet him yeah like I just
don't even know what I would say or do
it yeah I'm like terrified like I don't
I don't know what I would say to GSP I
have nothing to say well I would just
stand there and like stare at him like
drool I would do I mean is GSP should
buy it buy it with your money GSP all
right that's fair
who spends the most time between us on
the internet say our answer and three me
Jenna we both think we spend more time
[Laughter]
does pop a pair and candy crush counter
oh my god I've been using the internet
for longer so I feel like yeah but
that's why I have four hours that's
that's fair that's why I was trying to
clarify the question who has spent more
time or who does today spend more time
but an argument could be made for both
of us hey I used to write for the paper
just like you used to write for a blog I
was on the air and all
mmm yeah it's a lot of internet time
time so hanta Jenna's number of shoes
how many pairs of shoes does Jenna have
I don't even for the record I do not
yeah this is not an accurate figure it's
just we're basing it off of what Jenna
Rose had to guess I guess what's your
guy's 14 really yeah I said 24 oh my god
well because I was doing the math in my
head I think in that cabinet cuz this is
include including like slippers yeah
like those rain boots and then one peach
has in her mouth right now yeah and what
else like a couple pairs of eggs like
they're wearing right now I'm wearing
sneakers oh yeah but like I have a lot
of heels you do probably have 14 heels
yeah I was thinking I was like trying to
do the math in that cabinet like how
many are in each [ __ ] shoes 24 is
probably even low I don't know what I
was thinking with 14 dammit I think
that's a lot of [ __ ] shoes we can
count after well I mean one of them I
can never wear again cuz peach is eating
them yeah but those were broke anyway
like over three years old she's eating
my shoes - so it's Kermit Kermit spewed
on my whatever we're not going I like
this one Jenna's greatest phobia you go
first
zippers being zip that's not my greatest
phobia there's definitely I'm terrified
but you have to clarify okay can i
clarify all right if Jenna's wearing a
zipper and usually zip it like while
it's on her body and you zip it for her
even down doesn't have to be up even if
he zip it down she freaks out she hates
it she's like I don't know what it is
she's paranoid about zippers things if I
somebody else on her body but you know
why
had this red coat that I was in love
with and it was pretty tight to my chest
and cuz you know you have to wear your
coat all the time in [ __ ] upstate New
York like 12 or 13 years old I'm totally
aware of how you wear coats every day
sorry
so this kid was like not even really my
friend just like this kid in my school
he was a little bit of a [ __ ] yeah
and one day he just walked up to me you
know he's like crawling around he's a
zip up your [ __ ] it's cold out there
and he went zip any zipped my entire top
lip into the zipper and it was like one
of the most painful things I've ever
felt in my life and it was like bleeding
it was awful so ever since then if
someone tries to like zip up my jacket
I'm like no no I can handle it myself
and it was so [ __ ] painful
traumatising well cuz your lips are
sensitive yeah [ __ ] yeah that's like
imagine have you ever really got like
okay you ever gotten your fingers stuck
in a car door or something yeah I
actually have really ridiculously
painful without it being like a broken
bone yeah just something that's like
small and super no that sounds horrible
I'd be just as scared of them yeah Saamy
greatest phobia but that would you write
extra kudos points for that I said
getting blood drawn and flying those are
both very accurate it's taken me quite
some time to be able to get blood drawn
without like passing out yeah and not
like the woozy I lost blood kind of pass
out like I'm just so I just don't like
it yeah I mean they're scary [ __ ] like a
needle going into your body and then
getting in the air and like it got to
the last time I'm terrified of needles
going into my veins oh let me describe
it for you um I think the last time that
I went I was just sitting there and like
sort of crying a little bit and she's
like are you okay yeah do you want to
stop him like no no it's okay like it at
this point this is you know this is a
good react PG shut up imma get her she's
alright alright be a flying
flying at all in the least and it's not
getting any easier either it's only
getting harder it is definitely what's
my greatest phobia I wrote some [ __ ]
I wrote sir MIT I had nothing that's
close something in [ __ ] is your
greatest phobia yeah it's a miserable
experience
yeah I'm constantly afraid of it with
your shoes though
like stepping in [ __ ] with my brand-new
shoes that the [ __ ] was on my grand
brand new clothes oh my god that's
happened more than once that Julian has
stepped with his bare feet onto the
ground in the middle of the night and
there's just dog poop right there just
waiting for you like nice and hot like
right on top of my clothing future girl
you know ken has behaved so you're gonna
have to sit and daddy's sure and behaved
girl I'm sorry about that that's
obnoxious that I had to leave the
podcast because you're being so loud all
right what is the most thing that Jenna
does I wrote makes the dogs howl for 10
minutes straight because that's not an
exaggeration that's probably even less
than the time that is true I said the
most annoying thing that I do is pick at
your skin oh I should've wrote that damn
but that's not annoying I just hate it
that's not annoying it's not annoying I
just hate it I like doing is like you're
yelling at the dog the dogs are yelling
it's like these loud noises that's like
sorry I just associate that with like
annoying picking up my skin is more just
like you're annoyed like I really like
to get out his like blackheads yeah she
grooms me but sometimes I like it
sometimes I absolutely [ __ ] hate it
so yeah that's that's all mad at me what
it was
you don't even plays over it you got so
angry at me well cuz she'll pick it
something and I'll say stop that hurts
and she's really quick and then she'll
do it more and it hurts even more sorry
yeah I say stop what the heck
and you're like what no don't yell at me
and I'm like what am I supposed to do
you're never gonna stop it's like this
horrendous cycle oh it's such a it's
such a bad cycle like she needs like to
fulfill it in her brain to get these
things out on my skin and I need her to
listen to not let me fight about it
alright what's the most enough do you
mind not licking my armpit Thanks what's
the most only thing that I do I said
that you kick the top sheet off the bed
I wrote that I wrote leave open cabinets
off the bet you hate that so but it's
like it's in my sleep
I do that asleep yeah but you never fix
it so [ __ ] on the bed okay lately a
fix it because I know what you [ __ ]
despise it so you know the like the flat
sheet on your bed Julian's body is just
like it rejects it every single night if
we make the bed and like pull the top
sheet up it's just like it's not always
just like down at the bottom of the bed
it's like somehow wrapped around me and
like choking me to death
it's like strangling me and I just get
so upset because I really like when it's
I like the top sheet it makes me so
happy I know I'm sorry okay that's
almost annoying you wake up I'm like and
then you can't find the top sheet
sometimes you take the top sheet off and
put it in the library somewhere and then
it gets separated from the set of sheets
Oh like where's the top sheet like no
one [ __ ] knows man it went into
another dimension just kidding you
probably burned them all you ready for
next one yeah what do you think our song
is
I wrote that Julian probably thinks it's
that Ed Sheeran song oh come on that's
like ten days old and I think it's be
pppppp I'll sign a detail that's our
song it's beautiful by Mariah Carey and
Miguel you know that no no it's also
details not el sonido that's not a song
I love how I like tweeted about that
song one time and everyone on Twitter
was like dude my uncle loved singing at
a karaoke like there's nothing to sing
you using BP BP PJ Scott Joe ppppp yeah
that's a great song if you don't know
that song you're missing out rip it up
on YouTube write some [ __ ] yeah what I
Grammy for my heart are you connected
what's Jenna's shoe size come on duh oh
wait that's the wrong card duh hey Nate
is correct ding ding ding I've been had
bought you shoes yeah
what's my shoe size I didn't know the
answer to this what is your right
I run 11 or 11 in half oh it's 11 or 11
or 1/2 I'm proud of you see I couldn't
remember if it was ten to ten and a half
or 11 or 11 it wasn't a 10 second good
work that was a good one thank you all
right you ready for this weirdest place
weirdest place we've kissed you go first
I don't know so I wrote on a kayak we
kissed okay yeah I'm Big Bear
we kissed on the toilet and it was on
the internet for a good month oh my god
oh my god I forgot about that
for those of you who's lame the story no
man we did Power Hour one night together
and we were so happy and drunk and happy
and drunk and we both had to pee so
naturally
when she went to pee I tried my hand at
peeing through her legs Wow okay so Joe
the joke is that we we always say like
Jenna's like I gotta go pee and I'm like
oh you want me to go through your legs
like I would always say that like just
as a funny joke like oh that's really
perverted whatever but we were just
drunk enough to like both be okay with
it so she sat down it was like yeah sure
[ __ ] try it it's never gonna wear
before she sat down I mounted my camera
she sat down I sat down on top of her
you weren't on top I was like I was on
my knees on the floor but I was like
leaning into you know you really
explored all the way out like over I
remember whatever the point is she was
going and I was going the point is that
it actually worked it worked it was
beautifully and we were hammered and no
like streams crossed like nobody got wet
nobody really it actually worked
it was banana and we were kissing while
we did it no we were not kiss we can't I
mean it's on video we can we can check
the tape only weekend though cuz I put
that video on private I know Jenna was
like the moment she found out like she
was like you put that up I was like
Jenna I needed to put them on private I
know because I'm I'm so like [ __ ] put
it on the internet man [ __ ] everything
no I was probably for the best
you can't you can't see any you can see
my butt and like one point not in the
mirror man you can't I know screenshot
and sentiments like yeah it's all you
can see your butt I'm fine with a little
screenshot about being out there
whatever yeah and don't worry about me
thank you
what's the funniest thing Jenna did was
he's drunk what's your answer
chased runners around with Jerome
[ __ ] Oh Jean that's true
I just took my giant banana Jerome and
tried to breathalyze the runners yeah we
were up so late that people were awake
running for the morning it was daylight
that was so fun
what did you write
I brought my breathalyzer out them
excuse me you didn't have to blow into
this a couple of people actually started
oh I know I was hilarious you know that
first picture I ever had I know taking a
cab to McDonald's hmm that's pretty
funny I was gonna say I was gonna write
almost locked our guests outside I was
gonna write that too yeah Ryan yeah Ryan
and all them came over and Jenna got we
all got plastered that's not even really
that funny though no all right funniest
thing I've done drunk I wrote that you
made awful macaroni and cheese oh that's
good but that's not funny it's just sad
it's funny in hindsight like the dogs
wouldn't even eat it yeah it was really
really really bad because I thought that
like instead of making the cheese sauce
like separate I would just like throw
cheese and milk in while I cooked the
pasta and it just no that's not what
happened you were trying to make a roux
like with the butter and the flour but
you put in like a cup of flour oh it was
too much flour you're supposed to use
like a half a tablespoon or like a
tablespoon of flour to make the butter
thicken and then you put the milk in it
but like it was just all flour and I was
hammered as like my surprise party or
something that was so drunk there wasn't
food at the party and it was so hungry
and like way too drunk and I was like oh
I'm just so hungry dude okay okay let me
make you something I'll make you this
really great mess she likes look at like
eat it no it's worse
[Music]
anyway I wrote help greg in my arms oh
yeah greg in walks around with him in my
arms like a baby like baby with her
mustache like am bi ba types of people I
hate
type of people does Julian hate I've
made a little list I said small men
mouth-breathers troglodytes cro-magnons
and slow movers that's amazing I didn't
that that's like a better than a list
and I wrote I just wrote lazy bland and
pretentious but those are the people I
really hate these are all the words that
you those are the words I use people I
hate smallman that person needs Smallman
what does that mean there's a person who
is so small and either in their brain or
stature that they have to puff out their
idiotic chest and just show you how
stupid and small they are they are
Smallman they even wear suits sometimes
like Smallman suits moment they have to
go to double XS to buy that suit because
they're so small you don't hate small
people you forgotten knuckle draggers oh
sorry slow movers slow movers make
Julian's blood boil my buds playing
right now just looking at those words
Julian just doesn't like people that
move slowly well why would you move so
slow what are you even doing that you
have to move that slow what okay tell me
you're not like in the hallway at school
behind some ass going so slow for no
other reason that it would just move
slow they were raised wrong and born
wrong that's weird
they were born wrong types of people
that you hate I just wrote entitled
pretentious aka Hollywood people all of
that all that I wrote arrogant
ungrateful self-absorbed [ __ ] [ __ ]
they just with a period which also
includes men that are [ __ ] [ __ ] is
with a period that's true includes men
than are [ __ ] arrogant though I
cannot stay entitled entitled yeah you
made it
I have nothing in common with you
because you suck the life out of
everybody because he suck the life out
of everyone there's a person that Julian
knows that I know that his way of like
talking to people is just making the
most uncomfortable I contact you've ever
had in your entire life and it's the
creepiest thing in the world cuz he
really just thinks that he's like that
[ __ ] amazing yeah so stop reminding
you it and he's also all of those other
things that's what makes it weird yeah
anyways anyways what's
Julian's best body part I wrote yes but
also I roll honorable mention to your
hammies okay your hamstrings I think
really they're pretty spectacular thank
you you're welcome thank you for that
whole answer that made me feel happy
damn I wrote but oh yeah you have a
great [ __ ] butt thank you
it sounds so weird but it's like you've
gotten a lot of compliments on it
because people said I got a good but you
do a lot of deadlifting you do a lot of
[ __ ] weightlifting but it's just a
like comes out really I've been told I
have a black person but no like black
people have a certain but where it goes
like out but it's like no you have a
very shapely oh if only I could figure
hugging him black man's calf they have
the most insane calves like rises up
okay we're just digressing sorry too far
too far you're talking about Brian s
weeks calves
oh my god my friend mark his brother
Brian he does calf raises more than he
sleeps so like he'll just be anywhere on
his daily routine doing calf raises
wherever he is and he has grapefruits at
the top of it is really like his legs
because he used to be a sprinter he
sprinted he ran track for UCLA and he's
an incredible athlete but his legs are
like
solid solid BAM just giant calf and it's
like oh when he flexes it it's just real
oh my god and he's a big guy not human
oh [ __ ] incredible good calf's are
like some some serious like feet feats
of strength yeah well he I was like you
know jokingly Brian how should I get
calves like that what should I do and
he's like oh you just stand still just
do some calf raise yeah wherever you are
tired from doing them like take that
advice for five minutes
when you're in line at Starbucks that's
what I did like waiting - I look a
little crazy but I can do it by the time
you're up at the front it's gonna be
burning you're gonna be on fire it
shit's hard it's but nothing ever
nothing worth getting it came easy ever
ever grapefruits for calves grapefruits
recap that's what I need to work on
Jenna's best body part what did you see
previous card I knew you're gonna say
that but so I wrote my dead lifeless
shark eyes oh my god alright fair enough
I have the shark eyes like spearmint
Sarah map event shark we received
pictures of Sarah myths he just has dead
lifeless shark eyes he does I am and
lifeless shark eggs okay the next one is
what's Julian's best characteristic
would you write I wrote he Aries style
just does hmm yeah so Julian is an Aries
and Aries just [ __ ] get [ __ ] done
yeah so like whenever Julian has like an
idea in his head he just [ __ ] does it
like when we first started hanging out
your hair was what like an inch and a
half long yeah and he woke up one
morning was just like oh my god I need
to cut my hair and I was like alright
like okay and you just could not you
couldn't do anything you couldn't drink
water we had to go to your mother's
house by the time we walked in the door
and I said hi to your mom you had all of
your clothes off and everywhere Clippers
going this and you had shaved your
entire like when he
decides that he wants to do something he
just does it like nothing can get in his
way at all it's admirable but sometimes
it's a little crazy I am a little crazy
that was awesome though I was like you
serious that's a good story
I wrote my laughs oh yeah it's pretty
dumb jazz best characteristic laughs so
down she's sweet to everyone
JK - but you are you're sweet to people
who can do nothing for you H ever and
it's very nice to see it's the first
thing I ever noticed about you that's
sweet you were - every single person you
came contact with no matter who they
were I really try I just have no reason
to ever treat anyone with anything but
kindness and respect until they [ __ ] me
over
in which case like you still probably
when Julian is home alone what does
Julian do what does Julian dois Julian
eat play xbox and read it
I just wrote read it and clean up I like
to clean up when you're not at the house
when Jenna's home alone what does she do
off Krosh campaign period dogs are eat
dogs period yeah I like to eat dogs okay
just clarified with barbecue sauce yeah
I wasn't ready yesterday and some they
were talking about like how dogs like
wouldn't eat their owner if they were
dead but their cat would well because
cats are just like solitary animals
dogs are like pack animals and and
someone was like hey I'm with the cat
like if I had if I you know if I had to
chop my arm off
douse that thing in barbecue sauce I
would start chewing it was like where
are you that you have access to barbecue
sauce and not other foods like my
apartment right now oh it's so [ __ ] up
about cats cats women yet tell me why
don't own a [ __ ] cat that's [ __ ]
why get out of here cat and I'm a life I
like I want to meet Gina and Jessie's ko
it's like a really cute cat I have two
kitties oh yeah that's right they do nya
and bamboo bamboo viola nylon let's
close my favorite movie
ah I didn't [ __ ] know the answer this
I wrote wall-e wall-e is Julian's
all-time favorite movie what is it
Big Daddy [ __ ] I did know that there we
go you got [ __ ] I got all you got
[ __ ] guarantee you I get this next
question right the last question of the
game Jenna's favorite movie I'm willing
to bet money that I get it right mmm I
swear to God if you make a weird yeah
that's that's Julian Julian if you pick
the wrong movie for this losing it
what's Jenna's favorite movie Wicker
Park
I wrote airplane in the jerk although I
keep money on it I could totally
understand how you could be severely
misled by my love for wicker park it's
not wiggle park
no it's airplane park or the jerk I
guess it's like too late I is there
amazing
oh man I'm gonna need to walk that one
off that's that's like like a park it I
used to fall asleep watching a chick
flick it's you and my best friend's
wedding yeah I know right I'm an idiot
no okay what happened well that was fun
though yeah that was really fun we've
never played that before the first time
we ever played the newlyweds game cuz
we're newlywed we just got
is on camera we're not gonna go there
right now
oh nothing against anyone it's just not
like a priority to me and just not
important I think your love and
commitment to someone that's so
important I throw a party for all your
relatives we don't have to throw our
party flower all the times it can just
be a little party just the dogs can come
anyway until that party happens you'll
be podcasting every Monday so thank you
guys for watching and listening to the
Jenna and Jillian podcast where every
week we get on the mics and you hear
Julian get mad at peach for deciding to
start barking the hour anyway this was
really fun I like playing games like
this yeah I would really like to and I'm
going to make a conscious effort to try
to have more people on our podcast yeah
it's just you know it takes a lot of
coordinating but we're up to it so I'm
gonna step that up so but we will be
back next week we're on Soundcloud we're
on the iTunes
sounds like a raptor being born okay god
alright enough of that alright thank you
guys for watching we really appreciate
it
[Music]